what we're going to do in this video is
start to compare distributions so for
example here we have two distributions
that show the various temperatures
different cities get during the month of
january this is the distribution for
portland for example they get eight days
between one and four degrees celsius
they get 12 days between four and seven
degrees celsius so forth and so on and
then this is the distribution for
minneapolis
now when we make these comparisons what
we're going to focus on is the center of
the distributions to compare that and
also the spread
sometimes people will talk about the
variability of the distributions and so
this is these are the things that we're
going to compare and in making the
comparison we're actually just going to
try to eyeball it we're not going to try
to pick a measure of central tendency
say the mean or the median and then
calculate precisely what those numbers
are for these we might want to do those
if they're close but if we can eyeball
it that would be even better similar for
the spread and variability in either of
these cases there are multiple measures
in our statistical toolkit center mean
median is for mean median is valuable
for the center for spread variability
the range the interquartile range the
mean absolute deviation the standard
deviation these are all measures but
sometimes you can just kind of get gauge
it by looking so in this
first comparison which distribution
has
a higher center or are they comparable
well if you look at the distribution for
portland the center of this distribution
let's say if we were to just think about
the mean although i think the mean and
the median would be reasonably close
right over here
it seems like it would be around
it would be around 7 or maybe a little
bit
lower than seven so it would be kind of
in it'd be kind of in that range maybe
between five and seven would be our
central tendency would be either our
mean or our median while for minneapolis
it looks like our center is much closer
to maybe negative two or negative three
degrees celsius so here even though we
don't know precisely what the mean or
the median is of each of these
distributions you can say that portland
portland
distribution
has a
has a higher center
has
higher
center
however you want to measure it either
mean or median
now what about the spread or variability
well if you just superficially thought
about range you see here that there's
nothing below 1 degree celsius and
nothing above 13. so you have about a 13
degree
range at most right over here in fact
what might be contributing to this first
column it might be a bunch of things at
3 degrees or even 3.9 degrees and
similarly what's contributing to this
last column might be a bunch of things
at 10.1 degrees but at most you have a
12 degree range right over here while
over here it looks like you have well
you it looks like it's approaching a 27
degree range so based on that and even
if you just eyeball it this is just
we're using the same scales for our
horizontal axes here the temperature
axes and this is just a much wider
distribution than what you see over here
and so you would say that the
minneapolis distribution has more spread
or higher spread or more variability so
higher
spread right over here
let's do another example and we'll use a
different representation for the data
here
so we're told at the olympic games many
events have several rounds of
competition
one of these events is the men's 100
meter backstroke the upper dot plot
shows the times in seconds of the top
eight finishers in the final round of
the 2012 olympics so that's in green
right over here the final round
the lower dot plot shows the times of
the same eight swimmers but in the
semi-final round
so given these
these distributions which one has a
higher
center well once again i mean and here
you can actually it's a little bit
easier to eyeball even what the median
might be the mean i would probably have
to do a little bit more mathematics but
let's say the median let's see there's
one two three four five six seven eight
data points so the median is going to
sit between the lower four and the upper
four so the central tendency right over
here is for the final round is looks
like it's around 57.1
seconds while the if we especially if we
think about the median while the central
tendency for the semi-final round let's
see one two three four five six seven
eight looks like it is right about there
so this is about 57
more than 57.3
seconds so the semi-final round seems to
have a higher central tendency which is
a little bit counter-intuitive you would
expect the finalists to be running
faster on average than the
semi-finalists but that's not what the
state is showing
so the semi-final round has
higher center
higher
higher
center and i just eyeballed the median
and i suspect that the mean would also
be higher in this second distribution
and now what about variability
well once again if you just looked at
range and these are both at the same
scale if you just visually look
the variability here the range for the
final round
is
larger than the range for the semi
semi-final round so you would say that
the final round has higher
variability
very uh
ability it has a higher range
eyeballing it it looks like it has a
higher
a higher spread and there's of course
times where one distribution could have
a higher range but then it might have a
lower standard deviation for example you
could have data that's like you know two
data points that are really far apart
but then all of the other data just sits
right it's really really closely packed
so for example a distribution like this
and i'll draw the horizontal axis here
just so you can imagine it as a
distribution a distribution like this
might have
a
higher range but lower standard
deviation than a distribution like
this let me just i'm just drawing a very
rough example a distribution like
this
has a lower range but actually might
have a higher standard deviation
might have a higher standard deviation
than the one above it in fact i can even
i can make that even better
a distribution like
this
would have a lower range but it would
also have a higher standard deviation so
you can't just look at
it's not always the case just by looking
at one of these
measures the range or the standard
deviation you'll know for sure but in
cases like this it's safe to say when
you're looking at it by inspection that
look this this green the final round
data does seem to have a higher range
higher variability and so i'd feel
pretty good at this this very high level
comparison